so this is the wall against top takes
basically is what you're saying yeah
you're standing on the wall your Lord
command on your watch against hot on the
hot take wall and we go against the
White Walkers every day every single day
he go Boulevard we're standing Bristol
Connecticut we are thrilled to have from
the ringer deputy of the ring of the
pride of the mid-atlantic region by way
of Syracuse Sports Illustrated
Grantland and now the ringer up from
talk to thrones which is on Twitter
every single Sunday night immediately
following the latest episode of Game of
Thrones the co-host of the binge mode
podcast very popular Mallory Rubin good
to see you here on the show thanks man
thanks for having me you want Game of
Thrones welcome to talk about Game of
Thrones
you know I tweeted out before last
week's episode yeah that it's remarkable
just how much joy a new episode of Game
of Thrones brings me it's I wish I was
thinking putting like the word
remarkable or just how unhealthy it is
in a way that's unhealthy it's beautiful
I mean how many things in life like
really bring people that much joy and
excitement and also like unite people
who don't otherwise have a lot of things
in common
yes that's one of the things that's so
cool about this experience it's like I I
fell in love with Harry Potter when I
was in high school in college for much
that same reason like I love the stories
I loved the book the movies were like
fine right but it was like getting to
talk to people about something every day
and like having someone recognize and
like not make fun of your obsession
that's like a pretty rare thing in life
actually it's very cool well I mean my
first initial thought about it it was
tough to get my wife into it as you
think it's like dung dungeons and
dragons like there's an 18 sided die and
you roll it and then suddenly a Dothraki
goes up against somebody from Dorne and
then you try to figure all these things
out how do you great I was glad I did
yeah
so but how do you keep track of all this
stuff because I you know I I think I'm a
very keen viewer of television in pop
culture but sometimes I need to watch
something 3-4 times you're going on the
air right afterwards and you have your
stuff locked and loaded I mean it's
tough it's tough too
that's the episode that quickly and
disgusted and like a hopefully
entertaining an intelligent way
immediately Blackburn I think you know
I've read the books numerous times I've
watched the show like every season
before the new season I rewatched the
entire series and like was for years
just doing that like we're fun with my
husband because we're nerds and really
enjoyed doing that um and so like doing
that this year for binge mode with Jason
concepción and doing that in like really
concentrated fashion was I don't know
sort of like natural I mean it was
certainly an extreme experience but I
think when you just kind of keep
consuming the content in various ways
and are constantly having conversations
about it you just sort of like avoid
hopefully too many encoding failures and
the world is really vast and I also
think you kind of at some point have to
accept that you can't actually remember
everything and that it's more important
to like have a firm grasp on the things
that like you respond to in the story
because that's also one of the things
that's cool about the community in the
fanbase is like the story can just mean
totally different things to different
people and like your experience with it
can be diametrically opposed to mine and
still totally valid that's awesome well
I mean we all still you know we hate
most of the same characters right I mean
nobody's out there on the don't pass
line of Game of Thrones saying they love
Ramsay Bolton as a human being on the
other I thought like you know what I
mean that would be a tough one really
tough without mountain your dogs I never
back read your back read your diary of
Mallory Rubin deputy editor of the
ringer talk to thrones every single
Sunday night on Twitter right after Game
of Thrones great watch she's joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show studio who
in the world would hack HBO to get at
the game of Thrones
scripts come on and put them out there
it's horrible I don't that you know do
you have you seen any of these NAT leaks
no I refuse to look at me to thought I
won't even read an article about it now
your attentional me neither I'm actually
like kind of living in terror right now
because you know our show is on Twitter
which is awesome and engaging with the
readers and viewers and listeners that's
one of the things about this whole thing
that's like really really cool actually
but I am terrified of just stumbling
across the tweet that's like did you see
you know seeing X Y or Z I am may like a
conscious choice not to look at the
week's I care about the story a lot
and I really don't want to find out
about like somebody's feet or whether a
dragon dies or anything like that by
reading like a reddit thread I think I
love like theorizing and speculating
freely is like a pretty right it's
really part of the whole experience but
I don't actually want to know what is
happening until I am watching it or sure
George ever write another book I would
love to find out that way too she's not
writing another book I think your
problem I don't think really you don't
think he's going to know I don't know I
don't think I'll finish yeah I don't
think so why not
because what's the point I mean at this
point in time it's it's now being
written for him in a way yeah they're
going based off of his outlines sort of
I mean although we did say didn't which
one was a kid Harrington or was it John
Bradley who came in here by the way in
the deceit in which you're currently
occupying kratom Valerie the King in the
north was sitting right here your honor
about an acolyte at the Citadel is
sitting right here and he refused to
give anything up about any fare very
well practices that he wrote but one of
them said that both Dan Weiss and David
Benioff went to George Martin yeah and
said beforehand this is the way we feel
it's going to work finish up right and
he confirmed he said that's the way it's
going to wind up and I thought to myself
when I heard that story he's kind of
like oh yeah yeah that's that's the way
it's gonna wind up yeah go with it I
know it might not here's my suspicions
about that I think that that probably is
like a focused ending on certain key
parties like John and Danny perhaps you
know the night were running right so the
thing about the books is that the world
that George has built is so vast and
sprawling and epic that like you know he
initially envisioned it as something
that can never be adapted it was part of
why he wrote it that way he actually
didn't want it to be adapted and Benioff
and Weiss because they care about the
story so much were able to convince him
with actually their understanding of
John's parentage that was part of how
they were like this is going to be and
your story is going to be in really good
hands but he could still finish the book
in 20 different ways or shift the
emphasis to certain other characters I
think the broad strokes of the ending
obviously has to be the same you can't
I have John win in the show and not in
the books but the world is so big and
there are so many people who are a part
of it that he could still do so many
other things I just think like you spend
21 years of your life working on
something 21 the first book came out 21
years ago so he was working on it before
that 25 years of his life and someone
else is getting to finish that and share
that with the masses that always be like
most debilitating donation know which
was me do yeah so that's really tough I
think maybe he waits til the show ends
and then gives another crack but he's
like writing another companion story now
guys he's like Targaryen history boy do
I have good news for you get a few more
thousand pages on it soon but I think
he'll keep doing that and then you know
we'll see Mallory Rubin of the ringer
will take a 60-second break we'll talk
some more thrones and then a little bit
of baseball I know your Orioles are in a
little bit of a roll right here at
Creighton I know I'm just wondering what
that actually means when it all comes
out in the wash the American League to
me is up in the air because it goostin
the way that they've been playing I
think they they can get got in a series
and obviously the Dodgers are a
different story Mallory Rubin of the
ringer when we come back here in 60
seconds
[Music]
nice play that
[Music]
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show Rich
Eisen sure listeners can receive a
special offer from my pillow comm click
on the radio listeners special tab and
use the promo code rich that's promo
code RI CH when you call 865-465-2249 I
think Danny has a big part to play in
this which is lately especially
rewatching the show in like two months
really concentrated fashion to do binge
mode I just don't like a lot of concerns
about Danny go in the mad queen route a
lot of burn the mall talk and when she
was back in marine with Barisan saw me
the one thing he said was like I could
just give you one tip things I learned
from your dad don't burn people just
like one note she doesn't seem to be
taking it so I'm a little worried about
that I think that Sam will learn
something key it's a citadel brand
obviously now that he had is the
three-eyed raven and has these visions
and is learning like right now he seems
overwhelmed by it he says it's fragments
can he grasp that information knows
hopefully soon I think that together
they will have the information that John
needs to go north defeat the night king
I think the question is when Cersei has
taken off the board does that happen
this season that question is what is the
culmination is it the the battle of
humanity versus the White Walkers or
does that get does that if you will box
get checked before the battle for King's
Landing in the Seven Kingdoms get
handled I think it's going to be the
other way I think we're going to take
care of like the petty human squabbles
this season and I think this season
probably ends with the wall coming down
that's my hope my sincere hope and
prediction it's just like check off the
wall at this point why is it there why
do they keep referencing that like the
night King can't cross unless it comes
down and he can at some point I think
that has to happen obviously you know
book readers will know about the the
lore of the last hero obviously show
viewers now are learning a lot about the
principles promised azor Ahai we've
heard about the stallion who mounts the
world from Danny's story I my personal
theory is that all of these are actually
the same prophecy and just like
different cultural spins on the same
idea and George's commentary on how like
different parts of the world kind of
like whether it's religion or just
society like wrap their own
understanding around the same concept
and I think it's wrong
I wrote a thing for the ringer last week
arguing something other than what I just
said which is that I think this is
ultimately the most likely outcome for
the story still is that it's John and
Danny together possibly even a third
party if you buy into the dragon has
three heads talk period maybe a lot of
people out there think you secretly a
Targaryen but I'm just I'm fully team
John I ride hard for John and Gus that
goes protect us the direwolf he goes
back on the show at some point well it's
funny Mallory Rubin here on the show and
we did have Kit Harington here a couple
of weeks ago I asked him what's the
craziest fan theory that he's heard of
and he said that somebody said it as
only a there's a go stream I love that I
mean I'm not what's the craziest one
you've heard oh my god specifically to
the show or any of it sir Stephanie I
think right now the ones that seem to be
gaining a lot of popularity that I don't
like are that bran is like X Y or Z bran
is the night king bran is bran the
Builder bran is every brand bran is the
Mad King and I think like basically if
that's true it kind of Rob's the story
of one of the things that actually makes
it really special which is like the idea
that your choices matter and that you
and your agency as a person is like
important and that the decisions you
make have consequences it's a very
double Dorian idea I love well it's a
great I mean look the stark family more
than any family has proven that is beat
that's the case you wouldn't talk about
decisions made and decisions roads not
taken and roads taken
not a bad choice exactly but the one
with brand just if we just get a little
deep into it here
that's the storyline that confuses me
the most impact where I sit there I'm
like what the hell is that about
has that been true for years for years
where I am I kind of get turned off when
that when that storyline comes up
because it's so difficult for me to
follow in a linear narrative right where
it's that's so way out there that if
that is the portal through which this
all gets decided I'm going to be a
little disappointed interesting I want
to see a fight I want to see a battle
when I see a dragon I want to see John
and the mother of dragons hook up so the
insight is that my design with you
you're like on board with the incest
that's fine they don't know what's
incest well I assume a fable learn at
some point I mean John has to find out
who he is right is it I mean like at
this point I mean then if I'm going to
start blushing
watching Game of Thrones wow it's a
little late I mean that's if you will
has left the barn John's too good for
her Wow I think you're probably right
good I don't think she would see it that
way Danny's really like buying her own
hype she knows she really didn't really
without there was the title title title
Joshua so Malory why wouldn't she have
sent the dragons already to start
burning everybody up it's like when are
you going to release these dragons on on
some horrible dancer that is easy she'll
have a clue what she's doing that she's
getting she panics - ever had a clue
what she's doing and Tyrion is a
brilliant social strategist and maybe
even a brilliant political mind but he's
not a military mind Blackwater was as
Jason concepción has pointed out
Blackwater was an outlier for Tyrion he
had a lot of help from bran he found out
about the tunnels basically Tyrians
entire life comes down to tunnels as we
learned this night so you can be the
Lander sneaking people out and danny has
made numerous poor decisions all of the
characters on the show have though it's
not fair to just single her out for that
but yeah I mean maybe maybe they end up
together sods on John are not actually
siblings so maybe they end up together a
lot of tension there though a lot a lot
of issues to work through already
nice Colin Mountain meetings Mallory
Rubin here in the Rich Eisen show and
Littlefinger I love him as a character
especially since he's the actor who
plays Littlefinger Aiden Gillen from the
wire caddy
okay
my home city now why do you think the
wire your Baltimorean that was ahead of
its time wouldn't you think they did
because that got no Emmy nominations for
Best Drama right even it got best riding
for David Simon yeah it just seems to me
that never got any because it was up
against The Sopranos is the Sopranos era
sort of the way that you know Ewing was
in the Jordan era we know there was a
problem well like it's a wire we're
airing right now during peak TV people
wouldn't talk about the numbers it would
just be like art there are so many
choices consumers have so many things
that they can opt into or out of them
like right only this many people are
watching but that wasn't the case when
it aired and so the fact that they
rarely could crack a million was like
considered a problem but of course they
were innovating with storytelling in a
way that was really unravel didn't
Harlan okay David Simon is really
incredible a genius
he's incredible this word Illustrated
cover with the article he wrote about
the Orioles is like one of the seminal
text of my life
no kidding yeah beautiful moment when
they finally made the playoffs back in
no 12 I was incredible I have like a
blowup with that si cover mmm so cool
Mallory Rubin here on the Rich Eisen
show what do you think about your
Orioles they stuck in they didn't they
didn't trade Zach Britton thank god
they're two and a half out of the
wild-card right now yes they're on a
little run here just about the Royals
there it's a weird thing where like they
are on a run they are technically in
reach of a wild card but they're also
still below 500 like you know the parity
in the American League right now is just
severe so a lot of really bad teams are
technically in the hunt and I think this
is obviously why I like the last couple
years of trade market has shifted
because every team basically thinks okay
we're in it unless you're like you know
the Braves and you're clearly not in it
right I don't think that the Orioles are
apply often this year I think the
Orioles are actually a deeply flawed
team but that doesn't mean they are
incapable making a run I do not want
them to trade Britain that would have
crushed me you have one more year of
Machado he's still on the team next year
unless you do something criminally
stupid this offseason try for another
year and half try and then give up then
rebuild the other thing is like the way
baseball has changed you can't just
pseudo rebuild you have to try what the
white sox are doing now you have to do
what the Cubs and the Astros did you
have to completely sell process
load and attempt to basically lose 100
games so that you can then try to win on
well the Yankees started amassing some
young talent while under the cover of
the cocoon 3 that they put together with
Beltran and a rod and McCann who didn't
clearly work out you know where the
words thurman munson I think in Yankee
captain were mentioned in a way when he
came on board that they but then they
decided let's trade Chapman let's trade
Miller let's start getting guys like
Torres and Clint Frazier's been able
revelation yeah he's awesome who they
got in the Miller trade last year smart
to not know of him for Sonny gray I have
been a bad deal and then Aaron judges a
dream come true
Oh incredible it's extremely annoying
and no no why would you say annoying
because really nothing worse in the
world than the Yankees having a
generational talent it's no nauseating
hold on just a momentary cue she gets it
I will say this I will say that I care
about baseball as a proposition and so I
am willing to put aside how devastating
it is as an Oriole fantasy hair and
judge on the Yankees and you know what
that means for the next 15 years because
okay he's the first baseball player that
like the basketball fans in my office
talk about everyday right he's actually
exciting to people and at a time for
baseball when you know Manfred is
working really hard to get young people
excited about the game again and peace
of play is an issue and expansion as a
question and viewership has really
shifted to like being regional instead
of being national like she's a guy who
can maybe transcend that and actually
get people like jazzed about the sport
again that's awesome
I would love if people cared about Mike
Trout like the fact that maybe the best
player potentially of all time is active
right now that's really cool people
should care more about that yeah and he
made Major League Baseball history 2000
home run 20 more home runs 10 or more
stolen bases in six seasons before
turning 25 with a home run last night a
rods the only other player to do that
he's incredible I mean he is he is
incredible but let's get him out there
in the home run derby then right let's
get I'm serious and into October well
and I'm jobber part is key really nice
and angel right yes we're a little more
competitive and you know just be
as the Yankees are fortunate enough to
get a generational talent for yet
another generation
you know don't hate congratulate he's
been awful in the second half enjoy a
lot less bad at some high heat from
Mallory rube how Davis Larry I'm the
door please go back to the heart of this
chat I mean I'll scratch the surface on
what we can talk about you're absolutely
on the show Salem
say hello to Bill for me we please well
absolutely from Bill Simmons the ringer
Eric says I don't Eric Eric Weinberger
from back and we said we started NFL
Network together now he's with the
ringer with Mallory Rubin and then
co-host of the binge mode podcast as
well check it out
Mallory Rubin on Twitter one more TV
segment with Mallory Rubin when we come
back Terrell Davis still to come the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that video be sure
to download our app don't have any
memory on your phone let's start to
delete some of those slo-mo videos you
have and you know which ones I'm talking
about